hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
in this video I'm going to be sharing
with you the four ways how you can get
estate agents to like you it's really
important that agents like key because
people do business with people that they
know like and trust and if they don't
like you they're not gonna sell houses
to you they're not going to do business
with you so please stay tuned check out
the video and don't forget to smash that
like button below and if you haven't
already subscribed to the channel do
that right now
[Music]
having estate agents like you is so
important I've got a multi-million pound
property portfolio a lot of that has
been built up through estate agents I
became an estate agent I went and worked
for countrywide just for like six months
when I was like 21 and the reason I did
that was because I just wanted to get a
background understanding of how they
think these are a few things that you
really need to know it's really simple
but if you apply it it's gonna make a
massive difference to your business it's
gonna be an agent like you want to work
with you and you must do a lot more
deals whether you're a deal package or
whether you're an investor it doesn't
matter so first thing is this just be
honest
I know it's simple right but be honest
don't pretend to be something that
you're not if it's your first time
buying a house sometimes people feel
like they have to pretend you know oh
yeah I've been invested years you
haven't got to have a front just be you
if you don't know the answer to
something beyond it if someone says you
know are you buying cash or mortgage and
you don't really know just say you know
what I'm not really sure yet but I'm
really interested in this house so would
it be possible for me to have the land
like be completely honest be transparent
just tell them in your plans it's really
surprising sometimes honest people
usually get what they want when you just
trimmed apparent honest and there's so
many people out in this industry that
are just complete bloggers and they're
pretenders and you know gonna do that
man just be totally honest and be no
next one number two is be confident when
you walk in and you have a confidence
about you it just makes you attractive
don't be desperate you don't want to be
a motivated buyer you want to be a
confident investor that finds motivated
sellers so walk in there with confidence
and here's the thing even if you don't
you're confident you can fake that and
though they'd be honest of course you
got to be honest with what you say don't
try and pretend don't turn black but
have a confidence about you and don't be
afraid people think when they go into
estate agents that they're dealing with
all these you know really experienced
property investors that have been agents
for decades probably you're going to be
walking in you're going to be dealing
with 19 20 year old kids there are just
salespeople but happened to be selling
property they want to sell the houses to
you but you're the you're the customer
so be confident have a confidence about
you have a good energy don't be afraid
number three and again this is super
simple I feel that I need to say this
there's a lot of investors that ring up
agents and the agent will say you know
hey would you like to speak to our
mortgage broker and the investors like
no thank you I have my own a broker and
I don't know ever it's almost
compensating for trying to be
overconfident but sometimes investors
come across to a stage as jerks and when
I was in the stage and a lot of
investors would be like but they're
really really important they really
weren't because I've seen some of their
bank balances you think is really point
be nice be nice to people it doesn't
cost anything to smile to be kind and to
be nice it doesn't cost anything but it
will pay you back in dividends when an
estate agent tells past you go and bring
them flowers go in and say you know
thank you so much for this deal I'm
really enjoyed doing business with you
I'd love to do it again just be a nice
person smile be kind be genuine off a
good offer compliment but the rich of
authentic be nice and I promise you
we'll set you head and shoulders above
eighty percent of most property
investments number four and this is
arguably the most important and that is
this if you want to get in with in an
estate agent you need to buy from them I
always say your first deal is always
your hardest there when you buy from an
estate agent assuming that you did you
the three things and you're honest and
you're confident you're nice when you
buy from an estate agent or you'll find
is they'll speak to you differently
because you're now an actual customer
ultimately in a state agent wants to
make money that's their job that they go
to the office they go to work to sell
houses to make money they're on
commission if you buy from them
it means that that holiday that they
just took all that dinner that I just
went out for you paid for that
you're that customer you're giving the
money when you buy a house from them the
best way to get in with estate agents is
to buy from them
once you become a customer they'll treat
you differently they'll probably put you
in their little black book and by the
way these do exist
100% you might not be a physical black
book but estate agents do you have
favorites they do have people that they
call with the best deals buy from them
buy one house get in with them and stay
connected forever that's kind of it I
know this is quite basic but it's so
important because people think that they
need to be really intelligent they need
to be able to understand the difference
between yield a return on investment and
they need to be know all the jargon in
order to get estate agents to like them
and to give them good deals you don't
have to do any of that you just got to
be honest confident be a nice person and
ultimately buy from them love you
forever that give you all the best deals
and then hopefully when you've got a
multi-million pound property portfolio
you'll be able to said that most of it
came to agents which I enable that to
happen by giving you this piece of
advice guys I hope it was helpful please
drop a comment below let me know what
you thought this video of this style of
video I know it's not so much detailed
content it's more how to act and how to
be but I really believe it's going to
make you go a long way in the property
industry because ultimately the property
business is a people business please
subscribe I'll see you next time thank
you so much
[Music]